If possible, at least 7 people
, of course Levi is included.As you
know,
Levi was completely ambushed, and the residents inside us also suffered.
It's a
tough situation, isn't it?
After posting this narrow correct answer, what's waiting for us are days where it's better to die
But that's the same as long as we live inside these walls, is
n't it?  We don't know when they'll break through the wall and come destroy
us. We chose the
Kentei.  In order to find out
, let's believe until the end Read Kenny, who
says that this world will turn the whole bread place upside
down
[Music]
I'm ready, so how about your determination to do it to you
Sounds good?